[Music]
boys like this for our Halloween show
this is our halloween is coming up
you're excited I'm going out this year
as a quid pro quo but I love Halloween
in Los Angeles the women they always say
I love dressing up and then they go out
wearing nothing but underwear and kitten
ears that's this is duly noted sir but
this is a very beautiful time here in
Southern California I think mid-fall
right it's a lot like New England or our
trees turning a beautiful shade of red
and gold that's because they're on fire
here that's yeah we have a fine 600
fires going it can be very confusing
among the the hipsters out here because
a kid said to me today
that's fire I didn't know who's
complimenting my shirt or talking about
something sparking up
Trump says he will send federal aid for
the fires but first we have to come up
with some dirt on Joe Biden so that's
all this this this impeachment inquiry
is making a crazy person crazy he's yeah
the other day he said the impeachment
inquiry was a lynching don't you love
that about Donald Trump even when he's
fighting for his political life he still
is able to squeeze in a little racism
you know he's a an his his level of
self-pity I don't think we could ever
measure this you know I it's
awe-inspiring it's like the depths of
the universe that every day the
President of the United State acts like
a high school girl who was sopping into
his pillow that everybody hates him and
all his fans are like finally a real man
in the White House I mean he's
oh it's not crazy or anything but today
he ordered the Justice Department get
this to investigate the Justice
Department yeah no he's been asking us
for a while he's mad at the Justice
Department for conducting of course the
Russian Muller inquiry so he's having
the good people at the Justice
Department look into those horrible
people at the Justice Department which
explains the new chant at the rallies
lock me up well what-what sent him off
the rails was testimony from this guy
named Bill Taylor I've never heard of
this guy we shouldn't diese one of those
deep state heroes you don't hear about
our top guy who was in Ukraine
he gave the testimony incredibly
credible east west point served in
Vietnam all the credibility in the world
the upshot was Trump did it he did
exactly what he was being accused of
doing there is nothing left the
Republicans to go to except physically
disrupting the hearings which they did a
bunch of the Republican lawmakers barged
into closed-door proceedings because
that's how you handle a lynching by
sending in a mob of angry white men
and the Republicans were all saying the
Democrats are holding a secret inquiry
if it that one ass in they were chanting
lettuce lettuce in your already end
there are Republicans on the committee
already they are inside asking any
questions they want and they claim
they're being shut out shut out it's
like the houston astros saying we're
being shut out of the World Series no no
you're just losing the World Series that
you're not being shut out of it oh
speaking of the World Series Trump says
he is going to a game five if there is a
game five he doesn't really like
baseball but he'll go anywhere where
there's a chance a Latino might run into
a wall
but he says no throwing out the first
pitch you know president no and he's not
gonna do that he said he'd like to but
throwing makes his tits jiggle it's it's
just getting so mad King out there today
I'm not making this up Trump ordered the
government everybody in the government
to cancel subscriptions to the New York
Times and The Washington Post
he's like louis xiv don't don't show me
anything sad I only want to see pretty
things no really
here in the government and you're not
allowed to have a newspaper Melania was
pissed she said no newspapers what am I
going to use to line my cage
and yet what are people talking about
they're talking about a congresswoman
from right up north here
Palmdale area anyone from that area your
Congress but Katie held yeah yeah
exactly
no her going through a divorce the
husband boy divorce is rough
gladinet that did that the ex put out
photos of her nude making out with a
woman smoking a bomb I was shocked a
bong in 2019
no I think it's great I think it's about
time a congresswoman got down with
another woman and it explains her slogan
I'm with her she and her husband and the
woman they were this was a relationship
like a real relay of Rumpel they call it
only Millennials could ruin threesomes
by making the monogamous I gotta tell
you but finally I have important news
again California news Felicity Huffman
was released today after serving 11 of
her 14 day sentence that the good news
for her is that she got out early the
bad news is that she is now a member of
the Aryan Brotherhood
you